Fueron médicos del noreste de Brasil
los primeros en detectar hace un año, tras un brote de Zika,
que había habido un aumento de casos de microcefalia.
Tardaron otro año
para asegurarse de que fue causado por el virus del Zika,
pero ahora están seguros.
Y si les hacen falta pruebas,
miren esta publicación.
Entonces, ¿de dónde vino, y cómo llegó aquí?
Y está aquí.
Como muchos virus, se originó en África,
en concreto, en el bosque de Zika en Uganda.
Científicos del cercano instituto Yellow Fever Research
identificaron un virus desconocido en un mono en el bosque de Zika
y de allí su nombre.
Los primeros casos de Zika en humanos
aparecieron algunos años más tarde en Uganda y en Tanzania.
El virus se extendió luego por África occidental
y al este en Asia ecuatorial: Pakistán, India, Malasia, Indonesia.
Pero todavía solo en monos y, por supuesto, en mosquitos.
De hecho, en los 60 años
entre 1947, cuando se identificó por primera vez, y 2007,
solo hubo 13 casos oficiales de fiebre de Zika en humanos.
Y luego ocurrió algo extraordinario
en las diminutas islas de Yap de Micronesia,
hubo un brote que afectó al 75 % de la población.
¿Cómo llegó allí? Por aire.
Actualmente hay 2000 millones de pasajeros en aerolíneas comerciales.
Un pasajero infectado puede embarcarse en un avión
y volar por medio mundo
antes de desarrollar los síntomas, si es que acaso lo hace.
Cuando aterriza, los mosquitos locales empiezan a picarle y propagan la fiebre.
La fiebre de Zika resurgió en 2013 en la Polinesia Francesa.
En diciembre de ese año,
los mosquitos la estaban transmitiendo por la zona.
Esto provocó un brote masivo que afectó a casi 30 000 personas.
Desde allí se propagó por el Pacífico.
Hubo brotes en las Islas Cook, en Nueva Caledonia,
en Vanuatu, en las Islas Salomón
y casi toda la costa de América del Sur y la Isla de Pascua.
Luego, a principios de 2015,
hubo un aumento de casos de un síndrome similar al dengue
en la ciudad de Natal en el noreste de Brasil.
El virus no era dengue, era Zika, y se propagó rápidamente.
Recife, un gran centro metropolitano costero,
se convirtió pronto en el epicentro.
Se ha especulado
que fueron los aficionados de la Copa Mundial de fútbol de 2014
los que introdujeron el virus,
pero quizás fueron unos isleños
que participaron en el campeonato de canoas de Río de ese año
los que lo trajeron.
Hoy, solo un año más tarde,
el virus se transmite localmente por los mosquitos
prácticamente en toda América del Sur, Centroamérica,
México y las Islas del Caribe.
Hasta este año, los miles de casos diagnosticados en EE.UU.,
se habían contraído en otro lugar.
Pero este verano ya se está transmitiendo en Miami.
Está aquí.
Y, ¿qué hacemos al respecto?
Para prevenir infecciones,
o se protege a la gente, o bien se eliminan los mosquitos.
Centrémonos primero en la gente.
Pueden vacunarse.
No viajar a zonas infectadas,
o taparse y aplicar repelente de insectos.
Vacunarse no es una opción, porque no hay una vacuna todavía
y probablemente no la haya hasta dentro de unos años.
Permanecer en casa no es una protección infalible tampoco
porque ahora sabemos que puede contraerse por transmisión sexual.
Taparse y aplicar repelente de insectos funciona...
hasta que se les olvida.
(Risas)
Estos métodos no resuelven el problema de los mosquitos,
pero es así es como se les controla: insecticidas.
Se necesita equipo de protección porque se manipulan productos químicos tóxicos
que matan tanto a personas como a mosquitos,
aunque haría falta mucho más para matar a una persona.
Estas son fotos de Brasil y Nicaragua,
pero es igual en Miami, Florida.
Y por supuesto podemos fumigar desde el aire.
El verano pasado,
funcionarios de control de mosquitos de Dorchester, Carolina del Sur,
autorizaron fumigar con el insecticida "Naled" una mañana temprano,
según lo recomendado por el fabricante.
Más tarde ese día, un apicultor dijo a los periodistas
que su colmenar parecía haber sido destruido por una bomba nuclear.
¡Uy! Las abejas no son las malas.
Los ciudadanos de Florida protestaron, pero la fumigación continuó.
Por desgracia, también los casos de fiebre de Zika.
Esto se debe a que los insecticidas no son muy eficaces.
Así que, ¿hay algunas alternativas más eficaces que la fumigación
pero más ventajosas que los productos químicos tóxicos?
Soy una fan de los controles biológicos,
igual que Rachel Carson, la autora de "Silent Spring",
el libro que inició el movimiento ambientalista.
Este libro da un ejemplo
de un insecto muy desagradable causante de una plaga del ganado
que fue eliminado en el siglo pasado.
Nadie conoce hoy esa historia extraordinaria.
Así que junto a Jack Block la contamos en un editorial que estábamos escribiendo
sobre el problema actual de los mosquitos.
En resumidas palabras, las crisálidas, que son la forma previa al insecto,
fueron irradiadas hasta la esterilización, llegaron a la edad adulta
y luego se las soltó desde aviones por todo el suroeste, el sureste
y hasta llegar a México y Centroamérica;
literalmente cientos de millones fueron soltadas desde pequeños aviones.
Así se eliminó esa terrible plaga de insectos
en gran parte del hemisferio occidental.
El verdadero propósito de nuestro editorial
era informar a los lectores cómo podemos lograrlo hoy,
no con radiación, sino con nuestros conocimientos de genética.
Déjenme explicar.
Este es el malo: Aedes aegypti.
Es el portador más común de enfermedades
no solo como el Zika sino el dengue, chikunguña o el virus del Nilo occidental
y esa peste antigua, la fiebre amarilla.
Es un mosquito urbano, y es la hembra la que hace el trabajo sucio.
Pica y usa su festín de sangre para alimentar a sus crías.
Los machos no pican y ni siquiera tienen la anatomía bucal para hacerlo.
La pequeña empresa británica Oxitec modificó genéticamente ese mosquito
para que al cruzarse con una hembra silvestre,
los huevos no lleguen a desarrollarse.
Les mostraré.
Este es el ciclo reproductivo normal.
Los mosquitos de Oxitec están diseñados
para que al aparearse con las hembras silvestres,
los huevos no se desarrollen.
¿Suena imposible?
Les mostraré de forma esquemática cómo lo hacen.
Esto representa el núcleo de una célula de mosquito
y ese enredo en el medio representa su genoma,
la suma total de sus genes.
Los científicos añadieron un gen
que codifica una proteína, representada aquí por esta bola naranja,
que se alimenta de sí misma para seguir produciendo más proteína.
Las copias adicionales, sin embargo, bloquean los genes de los mosquitos,
matando al organismo.
Para mantenerlo vivo en el laboratorio usan un compuesto llamado tetraciclina.
La tetraciclina inhibe el gen y permite un desarrollo normal.
Añadieron otro pequeño gen para poder estudiar lo que ocurre:
es un gen que hace brillar al insecto bajo una luz ultravioleta,
para poder seguirlos, ver hasta dónde llegan una vez liberados,
cuánto tiempo viven
y todo tipo de información necesaria para un buen estudio científico.
Ahora estas son las larvas
y en esta etapa, las hembras son más grandes que los machos.
Eso les permite clasificarlos por sexo
y solo dejar a los machos que lleguen a la edad adulta.
Les recuerdo que los machos no pican.
De allí en adelante es bastante simple.
Llenan recipientes de mosquitos machos,
los cargan en cartones de leche y los sueltan por la ciudad
guiados por un GPS.
Aquí está el alcalde de una ciudad liberando el primer lote
de lo que ellos llaman el "Aedes bueno".
Me encantaría decirles que es una ciudad estadounidenses, pero no.
Es Piracicaba, Brasil.
Lo sorprendente es que en solo un año
los casos de dengue se redujeron en un 91 %.
Eso es mejor de lo que se puede hacer con cualquier insecticida.
Entonces, ¿por qué no se usa este control biológico en EE.UU.?
Porque es un OMG: un organismo modificado genéticamente.
Vean el subtítulo aquí que dice que si el gobierno lo permitiera,
podrían hacer lo mismo aquí, cuando llegue el Zika.
Y por supuesto ya ha llegado.
Y ahora tengo que resumirles
la tortuosa y larga historia en EE.UU. de la normativa de la ingeniería genética.
En EE.UU. hay tres agencias
que regulan los organismos modificados genéticamente:
la Administración de Alimentos y Medicamentos,
la Agencia de Protección del Medioambiente
y el Ministerio de Agricultura.
Tardaron dos años en decidir que sería
la Administración de Alimentos y Medicamentos,
la encargada de regular los mosquitos modificados genéticamente,
con un nuevo medicamento animal, si eso tiene algún sentido.
Tardaron otros cinco años en convencer a la Administración
de que esto no dañaría a la gente
y no era nocivo para el medioambiente.
Este verano, por fin les dieron permiso
para una pequeña prueba en los Cayos de Florida,
donde se les esperaba dos años antes cuando la zona tuvo un brote de dengue.
¡Pero no iba a ser tan sencillo!
Cuando los residentes locales oyeron
que iban a experimentar con mosquitos modificados genéticamente en la zona
algunos organizaron protestas.
Organizaron incluso una petición en línea con este logotipo tan bonito
que finalmente recogió unas 160 000 firmas
y exigieron un referéndum
que se llevará a cabo en solo un par de semanas
acerca de la posibilidad de hacer el experimento en primer lugar.
Es en Miami donde se necesitan mejores controles de insectos.
Y allí, la actitud está cambiando.
De hecho, muy recientemente un grupo bipartidista de más de 60 legisladores
escribió a la ministra de Salud, Sylvia Burwell,
pidiendo que acelere, a nivel federal,
el acceso de Florida a esta nueva tecnología.
Así que la conclusión es esta:
que el control biológico de insectos inofensivos
puede ser más eficaz y mucho más respetuoso con el medioambiente
que los insecticidas, que son tóxicos.
Funcionaban en tiempos de Rachel Carson y sigue funcionando hoy en día.
Lo que ha cambiado es que sabemos más de genética de lo que sabíamos antes
y por tanto, podemos usar esta información
para llevar a cabo estos controles biológicos.
Espero haber despertado su curiosidad para que inicien su propia investigación
no solo acerca de los mosquitos modificados genéticamente,
sino también de otros organismos modificados genéticamente
tan controvertidos hoy en día.
Creo que si hacen eso
y hacen a un lado la información errónea y el márquetin
de la industria de alimentos ecológicos y otros activistas ambientales
y encuentran los datos, de la ciencia rigurosa,
les sorprenderá gratamente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)